okay I see only one that's our speaker
who is in open source Enthusiast and
Google summer of code mentor uh shivai
an expert in devops ml and full stack
developer we'll talk about uh building
machine learning microservices and ml
Ops using Union ml thank you
all right uh so first of all I'm super
excited to be presenting here it's my
first Pi data conference in person as a
speaker I've previously been also an
organizer for pi data Delhi so I'm part
of the pi data daily group and I've also
given a few talks at biodata Global so
super excited for that and unfortunately
my co-speaker gaurav could not make it
because he had to fly in uh to India
during an emergency but both of us
actually presented uh the same title of
our talk as a as a poster presentation
this last week at pycon so we'll be more
than happy to share that as well but
yeah without wasting any further time
let's get started uh so I'm sure I'm a
develop positions engineer at millisecs
and I've previously been also I've
worked with Union Ai and a lot of my
expertise and my experience has
primarily been in the space of machine
learning and devops uh so continuing to
project say Cube flow and yeah so if you
want to connect with us these are our
Twitter handles
ah so the of course I mean this is a pi
data Meetup and its conference and so a
lot of you might be aware of what
machine learning is but just a quick
show of hands how many of you are aware
of the machine learning life cycle
is everyone aware of the general machine
learning life cycle and it appears to be
quite a few of you but I'll just quickly
reiterate of what happens right we
should start with
um probably a data set that you can
collect then of course uh since that
data set might be having of different
resources so you might have to clean it
then you'll do a bit of ether
engineering then you'll pass that
particular data inside of a machine
learning model to train that model and
it will help you to set the weights and
biases for that particular data and then
once the model has been trained you will
go ahead and uh then predict and see
whether the model actually makes correct
predictions and if it does then you will
go ahead and deploy that model and if
you look at this entire machine learning
lifecycle uh of course the entire ml
code that you will write with it is a
very small part of the entire machine
Learning System so other things that
come as part of the entire machine
learning system include things like the
setting up of the infrastructure that is
required to actually run these models
and train predict and then of course you
have to continuously monitor your models
once they go into into production as
well and of course like they did a
collection itself is a very major uh
overhead for the data scientists for
machine learning Engineers when they are
dealing with the training of the models
and um of course one of the key things
to always also keep in mind is that
traditionally if you look at the vision
of data scientists or the way that they
kind of look at devops right so as a
data scientist their primary job is to
collect the data and then ensure that
the models that they train are fit well
with the result and when it comes to
like probably uh asking them that hey
would you like to probably also predict
or probably just go ahead and
productionize this model so go ahead and
work with things like devops they try to
shy away and especially it also happens
with devops Engineers as well if you ask
them that hey uh would you want to
probably work on a non-software
engineering related workload that could
be a to deploy machine learning model
they probably might shy wave and uh
that's a common misconception that
people have so if you're doing some kind
of a machine learning engineering it's I
would say very similar to a standard
software development engineering as well
so the same set of tools that you
typically use for a devops workflow for
a soft foreign project can be applied to
a machine learning project as well so
what we say is that essentially mlops is
a subset of devops similarly how Dev on
software development requires devops you
need machine learning envelopes for
machine learning projects as well and
important aspect of why You Need
envelops Is that the machine learning
models have the tendency to deteriorate
over time and when you work with larger
models they can be very
complex they might require a lot of
infrastructure as well so for example
today we work with GPD so these are
large language models so you might not
just be able to actually work only with
one single GPU you might need a multi
GPU strategy as well and so with so many
Hardware requirements and with the tool
set required to continuously monitor
your model once it goes into production
envelopes is really the process of
deploying and then also monitoring and
maintaining your machine learning models
in production once you have done your
initial bit of research and trained your
model locally as well
and if you look at the state of
envelopes it can be very confusing so
this is from this has been borrowed from
the lfani uh which is the Linux
Foundation Ai and you can see that
whether it's for model training for
cleaning your data for uh production uh
usage and then monitoring your model in
production there are so many different
tools today that exist inside the entire
machine learning ecosystem that it can
be confusing to use uh to try to find
okay which one should use and specially
as a data scientist right the major goal
for a data scientist to ensure that they
use the right side of the right side of
data and also then ensure that the model
that they uh are fine tuning is very
well addressed to the data set that they
are dealing with so instead of them
having to worry too much about which
particular data to use their major focus
should be to ensure that the model that
they train is working well so the major
goal for this talk and what we are
trying to kind of overcome is that the
data scientists should not worry what
type of tools they are using and
especially if they are dealing with
these tools how can we lower that layer
of abstraction or that boilerplate code
that might have to write when they have
to deal with all these set of tools
and uh there are some other inherent
problems that we also deal with envelops
so of course the biggest one I would say
is that a lot of times when as a data
scientist or as a machine learning
engineer you're really iterating over a
lot of the different code that you write
in order to fine tune your machine
learning model right and this might uh
probably require you to use some hacks
but of course when you try to
productionize a machine learning model
those will not work as well so the need
for being able to copy or essentially
take that boilerplate code that you have
written while you are doing your local
testing uh a lot of times you'll have to
rewrite that same code logic when you
are writing your machine learning model
in production and when you are
essentially productionizing a machine
learning model and of course then the
other one is that there are so many
different tools and so many different
Frameworks to choose from so which one
should you use and in case you want to
probably switch between these Frameworks
you'll have to write a lot of
boilerplate code again uh for to fit
your machine learning a model data set
and then there might be a lot of like
lack of flarity when it comes to
deploying your model how do you actually
do that can we probably replicate it
across different types of data sets that
you might have or you might be dealing
with so uh the major goal of today's
talk is to essentially overcome some of
these limitations that we see inside of
envelopes
and another thing that we also want to
focus on is to be able to create a
standard and also unify the different
set of toolings that is available for
machine learning so similar to how we
have a lot of different web standards
um we have standards for apis open API
specs can we also Define certain set of
standards for machine learning as well
so whether we are dealing with uh
probably with data or data sets or we
are dealing with machine learning how
can we unify and bring in
standardization for both the machine
learning models and also the data that
we are dealing with right so that's the
major goal and that is how you're
actually able to achieve that with the
help of Union ml so Union ml is an open
source tool that has been built on top
of flight uh so if you're not aware of
flight there was in fact a tutorial for
flight Yesterday by Eduardo from Union
AI how many of you attended that
tutorial so I see a few hunts but um
yeah I mean it's a very well known open
source project part of the LF Ani and
it's so essentially the main goal of
Union ml is to provide a unified
experience that is very that you can
actually use to very easily build and
deploy machine learning based
microservices and we'll understand that
how that kind of works and how Union ml
actually works under the hood uh
throughout the course of today's
presentation but the idea really simply
is that you have a machine learning
project it could be as a python notebook
but you can convert that with the help
of a standard set of methods typically
these are decorative functions that are
provided to you and with the help of
this single python app which we also
call as a union ml app you can very
easily deploy these across a broad
spectrum of different
um ways so whether it's just with the
help of a fast API based web service or
even deploying it on a communities
native environment so that you can very
easily scale up your entire application
so as a data scientist you don't have to
worry too much about whether you're
dealing with uh like you know converting
your data from let's say a SQL data
store to CSV or you're trying to write a
lot of boilerplate code for doing your
machine learning inference uh depending
on what type of model you are using so
whether it's a pytots model tensorflow
Sky kit learning or Onyx model and
whether you have to think about okay
like how should I as a scientist deploy
the model given that you might not have
a lot of experience with uh doing that
so Union ml allows you to uh not worry
too much about all of that overhead with
respect to writing boilerplate code and
it provides you a set of defined methods
that you can directly use and very
easily build machine learning based
microservices
I mean before I go further a huge shout
out to Niels uh who I think I'm not sure
if he's present over here but he is the
original creator of Union ml so he's the
original uh author and of course there
are bunch of other um
who basically inspired me to like you
know work towards this unit ML and
really drive that this entire idea
forward that as data scientists you can
very easily create machine learning
based microservices as well
and of course uh what I mentioned
originally was that Union ml has been
built on top of flight so I'll also just
briefly discuss about what flight is for
those folks who might not be aware so
flight is basically a communities native
workflow automation platform that is
data and machine learning aware so
whether you're dealing with data
workflows or you're dealing with machine
learning workflows you can very easily
just Define your entire machine learning
tasks in the form of tasks and workflows
so if you are aware of things like
airflow uh originally flight was
um something like that is built at lift
and it is built on top of airflow so now
of course like it has a lot of more
capabilities as compared to airflow and
you can very easily just Define your
entire set of machine learning
activities with the help of these tasks
and workflows so the major goal of
flight is to be able to create this
workflow automation system and provide
this as a platform as service so that
you can very easily and reliably Define
your Machining work loads and scale them
up probably in a community's native
environment and you really provide
segregation for both your data
scientists and for envelopes Engineers
by the different set of tools that are
provided within flight so that they can
work independently and not have to worry
too much about the tooling or the
infrastructure that is required with
flight and one of the Core Concepts
within flight is the concept of
workflows and tasks so tasks are the
smallest set of tooling that of course
could be like you know you could have a
task for just doing pre-processing of
your data there could be a task for the
training of your data that could be a
task for doing the prediction and
evaluation and then workflows are
essentially a combination or you combine
different set of tasks together and you
can run them as part of a workflow so
they typically use something called as
directional cyclic does so that's dags
which uh essentially are defining how
these workflows run in internally right
and I'm sorry I think the
oh this one is still on okay there might
be something wrong with that one so if
you are able to see it perfect so
essentially these workflows run as part
of like the directionally cyclic graphs
and they help you to define the order in
or the sequence in which your machine
learning workflows are actually running
and then of course there are some other
features that come out of the box with
flights including things like launch
plans that help you to schedule and
invoke these workflows so there could be
like multiple workflows that you might
have defined for your project and then
you also get like declarative
infrastructure so on the go or On the
Run you can Define gpus CPUs again
required for the type of machine
learning workflow you're running and uh
flight is also language agnostic so you
get sdks for flight and Scholar Java
JavaScript and Python and so you can use
it for any type of language that you
want and you can Define these workflows
in that language and then so the idea is
that since Union ml has been built on
top of flight you get access to a lot of
different uh ml tools and we'll talk
about the ecosystem in a bit but the
idea is that whether you might have a
data store of snowflake or in SQL or you
might be using a machine learning based
model such as tensorflow pytots or
probably you might want to deploy your
model to bend into ml S3 bucket lambdas
aw Lambda all of that comes out of the
box supported with Union ML and the idea
is that by defining these different
Services as I mentioned these decorator
functions you can create individual
microservices for your training for
batch prediction online offline
prediction and scale each one of these
particular microservices on their own so
if you have let's say requirement for a
lot of like having larger amount of
compute power that is required for
training you could very easily Define
that just for your training function so
for your training microservice and of
course if you're doing some kind of
local batch product batch prediction
that might require less amount of
resources less amount of CPU bandwidth
you can very easily configure your
unanimal app to be able to do so
and here is an example of a end-to-end
dnml union ml app so the example that
has been described over here essentially
is an mnist data set which is a very
popular data set for different type of
digits and we are using a sky kit based
Logistics regression model so we'll just
go ahead and Define each and every
different step that you'll see inside of
this particular Union ml app so the
first one is uh the dependencies so
we're just importing the dependencies so
one that you'll see is Union ml so you
can get started with Union ml by just
doing pip install uniml and I'll be
showing you a demonstration for that so
here we just uh installing all of our
dependencies the next one that you see
is basically we are defining uh the
entire app so over here there are two
key aspects so one is the data set and
the model so the data set is one of the
core parts of the Union ml app so think
of the reset as the specifications that
are defined and of course here as an
example we are using the digits edit set
of because right now we have not really
imported our data set we are just
defining the name of our data set and
similarly we are also defining that what
is our model so in this we'll Define
what is the type of model that we are
using so in that case it's logic
logistic regression now the next one
that we have is that we have a reader
function so this is basically part of
our entire data set model within uh
Union ml so here we are really just
working with pandas or data frame and we
are importing our actual data set that's
from coming in from Sky kit learn but
the idea is that of course this is an
inbuilt data set that comes with Sky kit
learn but if you have your own data set
that that might be existing in a CSV
file so you could directly just import
that CSV file use the pandas dot read
underscore CV CSV function or if you
might have a data set that might be a
SQL data store so you could very easily
write logic that can convert your SQL
data store into a CSV file inside of the
functions that um are primarily meant
for your data set
and then we have other types of
decorator functions so the first one
that you see over here is the trainer
decorator function so this particular
function essentially takes your model
object instance and we are essentially
training and fitting our data set to the
model that we are going to be using so
in this case it's the logic regression
model and then of course as the next
step once you have gone ahead and
trained your model you can use the
predictor method to predict uh the model
once it has been trained and also then
use the evaluator method that's your
decorator method to evaluate whether the
performance of your machine learning
model is good enough or not so what you
see over here is that you're getting
these ready to use decorator functions
for reading your data set for training
for evaluation for prediction and as a
data scientist you don't have to worry
too much about writing boilerplate code
for what type of model you might be
choosing for what type of data set you
are using right because normally if you
were not to use let's say something like
Union you'll have to probably write 30
40 50 lines of boilerplate code each and
every time you are importing a data set
you are doing some kind of a
pre-processing of data or you're doing
your model training so by defining these
decorator functions that allows you to
remove all of that code and that layer
of abstraction that might come with
alongside with it and here is an example
of like comparing between so on the left
hand side for you yeah it will be left
hand side it's like a written an example
of the same Ms data set written in
um in sky kitlearn and then the rest one
of course like you it the code might not
be legible enough for you but that
example has been just translated into a
tensorflow based model so with Keras
and uh that thank God we have the screen
backup again so it's I think like the
screen is happy with how the
presentation is going on so far
uh all right
um but yeah the I think the biggest
point so far of course so far we are
just like you know talking more about
what you name it Union ml is how it
works under the hood but I think like
this particular uh screen and is
probably the most powerful uh tool or
the most powerful thing about Union well
and how easy it is to really deploy your
machine learning model with the help of
Union ml so you can choose whether you
want to deploy your unim your machine
learning model as a web service with the
help of something like Fast API so there
is a fast API integration that comes out
of the box or you want to probably
deploy your machine learning model as uh
as a service function with the help of
AWS Lambda or you want to probably scale
up your machine learning model in a
community's native environment so that
it could be hosted and it could be
scaled up and down depending on how much
traffic you're getting with the help of
flight so of course as I mentioned that
flight is a communities native uh tool
so you could very easily scale up your
machine learning model with the help of
live as a backend
and here is an example for like creating
a prediction microservice with the help
of fast API so the first uh code snippet
that you see is basically binding a fast
API app with a union ml model the second
uh screenshot that you see is basically
uh starting up a prediction server with
the help of Union ml surf so it's a CLI
tool that is provided by Union ml when
you do pip install Union ML and you can
very easily just start serving your fast
API application around and creating a
wrapper around your machine learning
model so that you could use it as a
prediction service and the third one is
uh we're just using like you could
probably create a client.py where you're
you're importing requests and then
running your prediction requests that is
running on your fast API server and I
also just showcase this as a
demonstration so uh not to worry about
that
and
um so okay and you could also deploy a
union ml with the help of Bento ml so
Bender ml is a very nice tool for being
able to do machine learning model
prediction and this actually came as one
of the latest uh Integrations for Union
ML and that also actually allows you to
deploy your Union Mail app to even more
targets so by default uniml has the
capability to deploy with AWS Lambda but
you could also deploy your unimail app
Union ml app with gcp with Azure by
using Bento ml so documentation for
which you'll find on the unml docs I
will share the link to the docs at the
end and you could also of course uh do
more things with Union Mill so you can
configure your enamel app to probably
request for GPU resources allocate that
on the go on the run when you are
defining your union ml app or you could
also Define clusters so if you're
working with something like an Apache
Kafka uh or probably with like let's say
with spark you can find these clusters
directly inside of your unanimal app as
well again for documentation for this
you'll find on the website for unml
and so the idea is that with the help of
the cnnml app that we have created
um it's running on top of flight of
course it's a very robust system and you
can create different set of
microservices for training for batch
prediction local prediction right and uh
so yeah I mean Union Mill really makes
it easy for you to be able to create a
machine learning based microservices and
then deploy them right and of course
this is a really important aspect of the
entire mlops architecture that
traditionally we use and again the major
goal as I covered is that it helps to
unify all the different machine learning
tools that exist today we saw that as
part of the entire landscape for machine
learning uh we saw that there are so
many different services so it's a very
ambitious project and it's still
relatively new so it just started off
last year and there are a lot of
different Integrations that are being
built right now to make it even more
accessible for uh probably for a
different set of other tools that you
might be using to make it very easy for
you to be able to write machine learning
based microservices right and here is an
example of the end-to-end Integrations
that exist today or are also under
development right now so whether it's
for deployment so with like Fast API
streamlit or fast or whether you want to
work with different type of data Stores
um different type of machine learning
models or if you want to like let's say
deploy them on service functions all of
them are inbuilt Integrations so you
don't you don't have to worry too much
about writing boilerplate code for all
these Integrations all of them come
inbuilt with uh uniml and when you're
writing your unumail app then you can
very easily use them
and here's also like the roadmap so of
course a lot of the production level
might like you know production level
machine learning involves uh
continuously monitoring your machine
learning model so you could probably use
tools like Prometheus grafana or of
course you might want to explain your
model like you know whether because
model explainability is a very important
aspect of uh ensuring that we are
creating good and explainable AI right
so you want to probably do things like
model serving so all these are like part
of the roadmap and might be released in
the next like few months or uh in in
years time
and of course now it's a demo so of
course it's going to be a small demo but
I hope that this gives you a glimpse of
the power of Union Ai and Union ml so
let me go ahead and see if I'm able to
bring up my vs code
all right so I'm just using a GitHub
code space uh because there's some issue
in actually installing the dependency
for Union ml locally in my system but uh
just a quick two to three demos that I
have prepared for all of you so the
first one is and we'll just wait for the
code space to start
all right perfect and I'll just bring up
my terminal over here
so in order to get started you just have
to very the first step that you'll do if
you want to get started with Union ml is
um use a pip install Union ML and that
would essentially give you the access to
use the union ml CLI so in this case uh
one minute let me just probably remove
this course okay so I'll just open up a
new terminal and if I zoom in a bit more
I hope everyone is able to see the
screen perfect
and so if I type Union ml you can see
that it works as a CLI tool and probably
it might be a bit delayed because the
code space is just starting so we'll
just give it like one or two minutes at
Max to be able to run
all right so you can see that Union ml
is working fine so in order to basically
create a new Union ml app you just have
to use Union ml
init so it's to initialize the new ml
app and just give a name to it so we can
give Pi data live
and what it will do is that it will
create a boilerplate code for you and
we'll see that on the left hand side so
over here it has created the Spy data
life and here you will find like a
sample data set with the app.py
containing the entire code so this is
the same code that I showcased in the
slides as well which is for the losses
logistic regression and it's loading the
load digits and we can very simply just
run this uniml app with the help of
python app.py so if we run this you'll
see uh just one second okay I'll have to
go to that particular directory so let
me go to the pi data live
and just run the python app.py so it
will go ahead and give a prediction
and so you can see that it ran the
logistic regression code it uh basically
gave you the prediction for both the
training and for the test and for like a
random set of five uh five data points
it gave you the prediction of the digits
so I mean six nine these are all the
digits similarly I uh made one Union ml
app myself before coming over here so
that one is actually for an iris data
set and over here so if you are aware of
the iris data sets are very popular
itself that has like three different
type of flowers a setos or C color so I
mean uh Virginia and the model that I'm
going to be using over here is a k n
model so it's a k enables classifier
again using the Escalon and I'll go
ahead and simply run this as well so
I'll just go back to my
code repository go to my Iris data set
and run the python app.py and over here
we are running the k n classifier uh in
this case what I did was at the end of
the code I just ran a sample of two dead
sets so we heard like what you see is
basically uh the iris editor how it
works is that it has three different
classes so you get uh and basically the
enums for them are zero one two so you
can see over here that we get a training
a score of 96 percent and test for 96
similar and I can probably also increase
the number of samples so probably from
two to five
and run this again
and in fact like this time I have taken
25 so you can run this and get a result
for like 25 different samples and the
third demo that I just want to quickly
show is for the uh fast API right so I
can go to the fast API demo and run that
as well so in the first API demo uh the
only thing that we're doing is that we
are importing fast API and wrapping our
entire fast API app uh in for our Union
ml machine learning model and to run
this you just have to run this
particular command which is the union ml
server so I'll go ahead and run this and
this will open up like my service in
localhost 8000 which uh will be live and
we can just go and see that in the
browser so that's basically our uniml
app and of course you could have
something like a client uh dot py which
can actually access to this particular
fast API service and print the response
so in this case you could just like you
know send a request for a load digits or
any other model that you might be using
for your prediction and use that and
since we are nearing uh on time I'll
just quickly also talk more about how to
get started so it's a simple one line
command pip installed in an ML and in it
my app to if you want like a boil blade
code so you can very easily get started
with this and if you like the project
you can give it a star by going into so
it's completely open source by the way
to a union AI OSS and Union ML and for
the docs you can read the docs over here
and of course
um this is the QR code for the slides so
if you're interested feel free to go
through them and you can scan them and
my my Twitter and my GitHub and yeah I'm
open to questions now thank you so much
thank you
thank you for that I was just wondering
does uh Union ml support more
complicated training paradigms like
distributed training or Federated
learning
so I think I'm I'm not really seen use
case for Union ml so far for Federated
learning but given the fact that it has
been built on top of flight so if you
have such kind of use case where you are
either streaming your data or you have
like let's say because in a case of
Federated learning you'll have multiple
Edge devices where you might probably be
breaking down your entire data and
training them separately on each of
these Edge devices right or what was the
second example that you gave apart from
the distributed training yeah so for
even for like distribute training it's
pretty much like this right that you
have different uh probably different
gpus and you want to train them
sequentially or you might want to train
them parallely on each of these
particular devices or you might want to
also probably divide your entire data
and then run inference on each of these
gpus parallely so that can be handled
with flight so um I've not really tested
it personally with unanml but hopefully
I mean that might be in the roadmap
gotcha thank you
any other questions
I think there's
hi uh thank you for the talk um
yesterday I attended the the flight talk
and
when or Eduardo when he was talking he
he talked about how you can also deploy
to like not just kubernetes but like
through like AWS and gcp and all of that
and how flight is kind of like you know
builds this abstraction layer for ML
orchestration and it seems like Union ml
Builds an abstraction on top of that so
I guess I'm still like a little confused
on
what's the benefit of using Union ML on
top of flight like in in terms of like
like I guess why are we not doing just
double the amount of work then yeah so I
mean that's a very valid question so see
the major goal for Union ml as I
mentioned earlier is so that um as a
data scientist I as I mentioned right
that you generally have to write a lot
of boilerplate code whether it's for
defining your model itself or probably
doing a data abstraction layer where
you're where you're translating your
data from uh probably let's say like a
data SQL data store to a CSV file
because typically like panda is Numb by
the they work with the CSV data file
right so the major goal for uh Union ml
is to go away with that layer of
abstraction and bring in Integrations
first for such a huge amount of
different ml tools that exist today so
uh deployment is of course one aspect of
unml but there are all these other
different tasks as well that you know
Union ml can actually accomplish right
so it's not just related to the
deployment as well but generally if you
also speak about like flight right so
flight of course works pretty well when
it comes to deployment on gcp Azure AWS
because you can Define like your flight
instance and you can host it on an eks
cluster or gcp cluster right so that's
the deployment side of flight only but
Union ml also helps you to deploy your
machine learning models not just on
flight or on flight native workloads it
can deploy it on as a web service it can
deploy it as a service function so I
hope that that probably gives you a bit
more clarity why there is a need so
flight of course is just an answer for
answering like communities native
deployments but we have all different
set of deployments that might not
require a communities native deployment
hi
just curious this might be either a
flight question or a union question
um so if you are for example using
kubeflow in your current environment
uh can uh Union flow and because Cube
flow runs on kubernetes and as I said uh
Union can work on kubernetes does that
mean that Union can work also on Cube
flow uh that's an interesting question
uh so that's something that I've not
really uh worked on myself so I think
like as far as the Integrations as if as
far as I know that uh there are no
direct compatibility as of now but
probably the union team is it's it's
also over here uh so I'm not really uh
aware of whether it can work on Q flow
but um I I know that there are some Cube
flow operators that are there for flight
so that might be a use case that could
possibly help okay and my second I got
one more question is uh can uh flight or
probably Union flow can do everything
that kubeflow does so can it actually
replace kubeflow yeah I mean there is
actually a Blog on the union site that
basically Compares between a flight and
kubeflow and I think um let me actually
go to that particular blog uh if you
have time so it's flight versus Cube
flow so I'll probably you could refer to
this particular blog that goes really in
depth regarding actually I was when I
was working with Union uh I was involved
in like you know distributing some of
this so but yeah uh feel free to go
through this particular blog to learn
and generally speaking like a flight is
being introduced in such a way that
there are some better features for
flight AS compared to even uh kubeflow
especially when it comes to dealing with
like notebooks and dealing with the the
uni like flight tasks and the workflows
that are uh built like you know they're
anogolous to the different pipelines
that we have within Cube flow so there
are some improvements that come with
flight over kubeflow as well
okay thank you so if there are further
questions feel free to reach out to
shivai directly and thank you very much
for this talk thank you
[Applause]